[Applause]
they got to get the ball in Balance here
just beat the five second count and here
is dinwiddy is he looking for a three
not yet dodo driving to the corner
Johnson the tie and he does it cam
Johnson
ties the game at 127 with 7.3 seconds
left bogey got caught
that was his obviously that's his sink
and his help but in this situation you
stay home
you want all twos you don't want three
stay home but it's okay now you have the
ball to finish the game and you want the
last shot yes absolute last shot you
have two guys that obviously In Trey but
dejante Murray so two guys now if they
happen to double Trey gets off the ball
trusting that Johnson Mary can make a
play for him as well
cam Johnson 27 on 10 or 15 from the
floor and he's not the point they just
said hey we're just going to get the
last shot so I like that little movement
first Trey get into the paint there's
got to go five seconds he comes over the
top one at four Trey looking to drive
shoots it
despite a rear contest from Spencer
Dunwoody Trey young hits the game winner
what a shot and that's a tough game
winner with somebody behind you and he
got it up on the rim and it goes in
gotta love it Ray's loving it Trey's
loving it the Hawks are loving it
129 to 127. and I thought for all the
world that Spencer dinwid who was going
to block it from behind
but Trey somehow got it off wow
[Applause]
the basket counts everybody's going home
Happy except the Brooklyn Nets
boom boy how does he miss that from
behind he was right unbelievable he was
right on it
oh that's a heck of a call there Bob
[Applause]
Trey young finishes the day with 34
points and beats the buzzer for Atlanta
so we have to add that to our buzzer
beater reel here's Trey with Lauren
thanks so much Bob appreciate it Trey
Buster feeder you'll love to see it how
did you get that shot off first of all
uh I mean I made him jump I mean I knew
that kale was gonna wrestle me and try
to force me into a tough shot but I just
made him jump in I was able to get my
photo off 7.4 seconds left what was said
there in the timeout heading into that
final possession uh Joe just wanted to
give me the ball in the back court and
get spacing uh for me to attack and if
somebody held up don't get on the ball
but if nobody else to make a play so uh
you gotta give Coach a lot of credit on
that last play for sure that second half
especially was a fight back and forth
just as a team how do you think you guys
were able to close this one out it was a
I mean a solo team effort I mean it
wasn't a pretty game
um allowing them to get back into the
game but that's the NBA that's going to
be nice like that and you got to find a
way to win and that's what we did
tonight I'm glad we did to get a win
like this at home you see all of your
teammates surround you there at Center
Court just what's the feeling right now
the vibe of this team after All-Star
breaks I mean the buyers is great I mean
when your winning is great so you've got
to continue to take it one game at a
time and continue to win very incredible
shot incredible win we'll see you
Tuesday appreciate it thanks guys
34 points in 34 minutes eight assists
for Trey and the game winner as the
Hawks Prevail one